Je pense que la grande chose est à propos
du livre de Max Brooks, il a placé le livre dans
ce cadre très réel et ce genre de
cadre de réalité et que ce
qui m'intéressait vraiment parce que je
pensais que je voulais créer un film qui
semble très réel vous êtes  dans un monde et
j'ai l'impression que cela pourrait arriver en
ce moment même à n'importe lequel d'entre nous et vous
savez que beaucoup de gens vivent
constamment dans cette peur à ce jour et à cet
âge que le monde peut changer à tout
moment et vous savez que nous avons vu  ça
change comme vous le savez, le meilleur exemple de
l'histoire récente est évident, c'est 911 comment
tout a changé d'un moment à
l'autre mes gars vous auraient et vous
aideriez le médecin à poursuivre toutes les pistes mes
gars vous sortiront doucement ma famille sur laquelle
le film se concentre  Jerry Lane qui est
un enquêteur des Nations Unies et vous comprenez
qu'il travaillait dans ces endroits où
vous savez que les crises existent, mais maintenant il s'est en quelque sorte
retiré davantage pour se concentrer sur sa famille
et vivre une vie plus
normale.  l'impression que si
vous êtes au milieu de vos activités
quotidiennes et que tout d'un coup
, une chose énorme éclate soudainement lorsque
le flic coupe le miroir, c'est en quelque
sorte le premier moment de tension, puis vraiment
tout commence à faire dérailler le  le film pour
moi n'est pas seulement un film de zombies, c'est une sorte
d'apocalypse mondiale épidémique mondiale
et c'est ce qu'un livre fait aussi et
c'est pourquoi vous savez que le titre de moi a
augmenté cette propagation mondiale qu'il ne s'agit pas
seulement de zombies fadhl facile mais
ouais  nous remplissons Newark nous sommes à propos de
Houston Louis Baltimore 11 gars je vais être
honnête avec vous je ne connais aucun
endroit chez moi ça marche très bien de
travailler avec les plus brillants incroyable parce
qu'il est la star du film et il est aussi
le producteur et c'est un vrai artiste et
c'est quelqu'un qui a un
goût impeccable et vous pouvez voir la
filmographie sérieuse les projets qu'il a choisis en tant
qu'acteur et le travail qu'il a fait et
c'est un acteur tellement sublime et intéressant et
ceux d'entre nous ont ne  Lorsque vous avez fait quelque chose
comme ça, nous avons dû tous les deux saisir l'
occasion et travailler à travers ce genre
que nous ne connaissions pas tous les deux,
mais créer toujours quelque chose de frais en vous